when we were younger i never thought i
looked any different than her
and we didn't understand why people
would be like are you actually sisters
you're like yeah obviously
my name is hannah brandt i play for team
usa my name is marissa brandt and i play
for team south korea and we're sisters
i was born in seoul south korea and i
was adopted when i was four months old
i flew on a plane to the states and
that's where i met my parents
i started playing hockey when i was
eight
and you started i started when i was
about five years old
we did everything together growing up so
really i chose hockey just to be able to
be with her but as i got older i really
learned to love this sport
we played together through high school
and then we went our separate ways for
college
and we're on opposite ends of the world
every day we talk and text and ask about
how each other's days lunch and games
and whatnot so yeah i mean being so far
away we stay connected somehow
i think it's a super cool thing that
we're both going to the olympics playing
for different teams and
in the same sport i don't know how
common that is so i think it makes it
that much more special for us but i
think for our family and friends that
they have two teams to root for
just
so happy to be able to continue to play
the sport i love and
be able to go to the olympics with this
one
[Applause]
hockey has shaped and
influenced both of our lives growing up
so
i can't imagine a better reason to be
able to go back to my home country
through hockey
for me going to the olympics has kind of
always been a dream of mine and then to
be able to watch my sister do the same
thing and to be able to go through this
experience with her is just a dream come
true
[Music]
you